what i did instead was return to what i
regarded as the
original cause of all the trouble let's
say which was the communist manifesto
and what i attempted to do because
that's marx and we're here to talk about
marxism let's say and um
what i tried to do was read it and to
read something
you don't just follow the words
and follow the meaning but you
take apart the sentences and you ask
yourself
at this level of phrase and at the level
of sentence and at the level of
paragraph
is this true are there counter arguments
that can be
put forward that are credible is this
solid
thinking and i have to tell you
and i'm not trying to be flippant here
that i have
rarely read a tract now i read it when i
was 18. it was a long time ago right
that's
40 years ago but i've rarely read a
track that made as many errors per
sentence
conceptual heirs per sentence as the
communist manifesto
it was quite a miraculous re-read it and
it was interesting to think about it
psychologically as well because
i've read student papers that were of
the same ilk in some sense although i'm
not
suggesting that they were of the same
level of glittering literary brilliance
and polemic quality and i also
understand that the communist manifesto
was a call for revolution and not
a standard logical argument but that
notwithstanding
i have some things to say about the
authors psychologically
the first thing is that it doesn't seem
to me that either marx or ingles
grappled with one fundamental with this
particular fundamental truth which is
that
um almost all ideas are wrong
and so if you and it doesn't matter if
they're your ideas or someone else's
ideas
they're probably wrong and even if they
strike you with the force of brilliance
your job is to assume first of all that
they're probably wrong
and then to assault them with everything
you have in your
arsenal and see if they can survive and
what
what struck me about the communist
manifesto was it was akin to something
jung said about
typical thinking and this was the
thinking of people who weren't trained
to think
he said that the typical thinker has a
thought it appears to them
like an object might appear in a room
the thought appears
and then they just they just accept it
as true
they don't go the second step which is
to think
about the thinking and that's the real
essence of critical thinking and so
that's what you try to teach people in
university is to
read a text and to think about it
critically not to destroy the utility of
the text
but to separate the wheat from the chaff
and so what i tried to do when i was
reading the communist manifesto was to
separate the wheat from the chaff and
i'm afraid i found
some wheat yes but mostly chaff and i'm
going to explain why
um hopefully in relatively short order
so i'm going to outline 10 of the
fundamental
axioms of the communist manifesto and so
these are
truths that are basically held as
self-evident
by the authors and um they're truths
that are presented in some sense as
unquestioned
and i'm going to question them and tell
you why
i think they're unreliable
now we should remember that this tract
was actually written 170 years ago
that's a long time ago and we have
learned a fair bit from
since then about human nature about
society about politics about economics
there's lots of mysteries left to be
unsolved but left to be solved but
we are slightly wiser i presume
than we were at one point and so you can
forgive the authors to some degree for
what they didn't know
but that doesn't matter given that
the essence of this doctrine is still
held as
sanchros act by a large proportion of
academics probably
are among the most what would you call
guilty
of that particular sin
so here's proposition number one
history is to be viewed primarily as an
economic
class struggle all right so so let's
think about that for a minute
um the first of all is there the
proposition there is that history is
primarily to be viewed through an
economic lens
and i think that's a debatable
proposition because
there are many other motivations that
drive human beings
than economics and those have to be
taken into account
especially that drive people other than
economic competition
like economic cooperation for example
and so that's a problem
the other problem is that it's actually
not nearly
a pessimistic enough um description of
the actual problem because
history history
this is to give the devil is due
the idea that one of the driving forces
between history
is hierarchical struggle is absolutely
true
but the idea that that's actually
history is not true because
it's deeper than history it's biology
itself because
organisms of all sorts organize
themselves into hierarchies
and one of the problems with hierarchies
is that they tend to arrange themselves
into a winner-take-all situation and so
and that that is implicit in some sense
in marx marx's thinking because of
course marx believed that
in a capitalist society capital would
accumulate in the hands of fewer and
fewer people
and that actually is in keeping with the
nature of hierarchical organizations
now the problem with that isn't so much
the fact of the so there's the there's
accuracy in the accusation
that that is a eternal form of
motivation for struggle but it's an
underestimation of the seriousness of
the problem
because it attributes it to the
structure of human societies
rather than the deeper reality of the
existence of hierarchical structures per
se
which as they also characterize the
animal kingdom to a large degree
are clearly not only human constructions
and the idea that there's hierarchical
competition among human beings
there's evidence for that that goes back
at least to the paleolithic times
and so that's the next problem is that
well
the this ancient problem of hierarchical
structure
is clearly not attributable to
capitalism
because it existed
long in human history before capitalism
existed and then it predated human
history itself so the question then
arises
why would you necessarily at least
implicitly link
the class struggle with capitalism given
that it's a far deeper problem
and now it's also you've got to
understand that this is a deeper problem
for people on the left
not just for people on the right it is
the case that hierarchical structures
dispossess
those people who are at the bottom those
creatures who are at the bottom
speaking say of animals but those people
who are at the bottom
and that that is a fundamental
existential problem
but the other thing that marx didn't
seem to take into account is that
there there are far more reasons that
human beings
struggle than their economic class
struggle even if you
build the hierarchical idea into that
which is a more
super comprehensive way of thinking
about it human beings
struggle with themselves with the
malevolence that's inside themselves
with the evil that they're capable of
doing
with the spiritual and psychological
warfare that goes on within them
and we're also actually always
at odds with nature and this never seems
to show up in marx and it doesn't show
up in marxist
marxism in general it's as if nature
doesn't exist
the primary conflict as far as i'm
concerned or a
primary conflict that human beings
engage in
is this struggle for life in a cruel and
harsh natural world
and it's as if it says if that doesn't
exist in the marxist domain
if human beings have a problem it's
because there's a class struggle that's
essentially economic it's like no
human beings have problems because we
come into the life
starving and lonesome and we have to
solve that problem continually and we
make our social arrangements at least in
part
to ameliorate that as well as to
as to well upon occasion exacerbated and
so there's also
very little understanding in the
communist manifesto
that any of the like say hierarchical
organizations that human beings have put
together
might have a positive element and that's
an absolute catastrophe because
hierarchical structures are actually
necessary to solve complicated social
problems
we have to organize ourselves in some
manner and you have to give the devil as
due
and so it is the case that hierarchies
dispossess
people and that's a big problem that's
the fundamental problem of inequality
but it's also the case that hierarchies
happen to be a very efficient way of
distributing resources
and it's finally the case that human
hierarchies
are not fundamentally predicated on
power
and i would say that biological
anthropological
data on that or crystal clear you don't
rise
to a position of authority that's
reliable in a human society
primarily by exploiting other people
it's a very unstable
means of obtaining power so so that's a
problem
well the people that laugh might do it
that way
okay now the other another problem that
comes up right away is that
marx also assumes that you can think
about history as a binary class struggle
with clear divisions between say the
proletariat proletariat
and the bourgeoisie and that's actually
a problem because
it's not so easy to make a firm division
between whose
exploiter and whose exploitee let's say
because it's not obvious like in the
case of small
shareholders let's say whether or not
they happen to be part of the oppressed
or part of the oppressor this actually
turned out to be a big problem
in the russian revolution and by big
problem i mean
tremendously big problem because it
turned out that you could fragment
people into multiple
identities and that that's a fairly easy
thing to do and you could usually find
some access along which they were part
of the oppressor class
it might have been a consequence of
their education or it might have been a
consequence
of their of their of their uh
of the wealth that they strived to
accumulate during their life
or it might have been a consequence of
the fact that they had parents
or grandparents who were educated or
rich or that they were a member of the
priesthood or that they were socialists
or
anyways that the listing of how it was
possible for you to be bourgeois
instead of proletariat grew immensely
and that was one of the reasons that the
red terror
claimed all the victims that it claimed
and so that was a huge problem
it was probably most exemplified by the
demolition of the kulaks
who were basically peasants peasant
farmers although
effective ones in the soviet union who
had managed to raise themselves
out of serfdom over a period of about 40
years and to gather
some some degree of material security
about them
and about 1.8 million of them were
exiled
about 400 000 were killed and the net
consequence of that
removal of their private property
because of their bourgeois status
was arguably the death of six million
ukrainians in the famines of the 1930s
and so the binary class struggle idea
that was a bad idea
that was a very very bad idea it's also
bad
in this way and that and this is a real
sleight of hand that marx pulls off as
you have a binary class division
proletariat bourgeoisie and you have an
implicit idea
that all of the good is on the side of
the proletariat
and all of the evil is on the side of
the bourgeoisie
and that's classic group identity
thinking you know it's one of the
reasons i don't like identity
politics is because once you divide
people into groups and pit them against
one another
it's very easy to assume that all the
evil in the world can be attributed to
one group
the hypothetical oppressors and all the
good to the other
and that
well and that's that's that's naive
that's naive beyond comprehension
because
um it's absolutely foolish to make the
presumption that you can identify
someone's moral worth with their
economic standing so and that actually
turned out to be
a real problem as well because
um
marx also came up with this idea which
is a crazy idea as far as i can tell
of the that's a technical term crazy
idea
of the dictatorship of the proletariat
and that's the next
idea that i really stumbled across it
was like okay so what's the problem
well the problem is the capitalists own
everything they own all the means of
production
and they're oppressing everyone that
would be all the workers
and there's going to be a race to the
bottom of wages for the workers as the
capitalists strive to extract more and
more
value from the labor of the proletariat
by competing with other capitalists to
drive wages downward which by the way
didn't happen
partly because wages wage earners can
become scarce and that actually drives
the market value upward
but the fact that that you
assume a priori that all the evil can be
attributed to the capitalists and all
the good that the bourgeoisie and all
the good could be attributed to the
proletariat meant that you could
hypothesize that a dictatorship of the
proletariat could come about and that
was the
the first stage in the communist
revolution and remember this is a call
for revolution and
not just revolution but bloody violent
revolution
and the overthrow of all overthrowing of
all existing social structures
um anyways the the the
the problem with that you see is that
because all the evil isn't divided so
easily up into oppressor and oppressed
that when you do establish a dictator of
the proletariat to the degree that you
can do that which you actually can't
because it's technically impossible
and an absurd thing to consider to begin
with not least because of the problem of
centralization
i mean you have to hypothesize that you
can take away all the property of the
capitalists
you can replace the capitalist class
with a minority of proletariats
how they're going to be chosen isn't
exactly clear in the communist manifesto
that none of the people who are from the
proletariat class are going to be
corrupted
by that sudden access to power because
they're
well by definition good so so then you
have the good people who are running the
world
and you also have them centralized so
that they can make
decision decisions that are insanely
complicated to make
in fact impossibly complicated to make
and so that's a failure conceptually on
both
dimensions because first of all all the
proletariat aren't going to be good
and when you give put people in the same
position as the evil capitalists
especially if you believe that social
pressure is one of the determining
factors of human character which the
marxists certainly believe
then why wouldn't you assume that the
proletariat would immediately become
as or more corrupt than the capitalists
which is of course i would say exactly
what happened every time this experiment
was run
and then
the next problem is well what makes you
think that you can take some system as
complicated as
like capitalist free market society
and centralize that and put
decision-making power in the hands of a
few people
the mechanisms by
without specifying the mechanisms by
which you're going to choose them like
what makes you think they're going to
have the wisdom or the ability to do
what the capitalists were doing
unless you assume as marx did that all
of the evil was with the capitalists and
all the good was with the proletariats
and that nothing that capitalists did
constituted valid labor which is another
thing that marx assumed
which is palpably absurd because people
who are
like maybe if you're a dissolute
aristocrat from 1830
and or earlier and you run a feudal
estate and all you do is spend your time
gambling and and and chasing prostitutes
well
then the your labor value is zero but if
you're
if you're running a business and and
it's a successful business first of all
you're a bloody fool to explo
exploit your workers because even if
you're greedy as
sin because you're not going to extract
the maximum amount of labor out of them
by doing that
and the notion that you're adding no
productive value as a manager rather
than a capitalist is
it's absolutely absurd all it does is
indicate that
you either know nothing whatsoever about
how an actual business
works or you refuse to know anything
about how an
actual business works so that's
that's also a that's also a big problem
so then the next problem is the
criticism of profit
it's like well what what's wrong with
profit
exactly what what's the problem with
profit well the idea
from the marxist perspective was that
profit was theft
you know but profit well can be theft
because crooked people can run companies
and so sometimes profit is theft but
that certainly doesn't mean
that it's always threat theft what it
means
in part at least if the capitalist is
adding value to the corporation then
there's some utility
and some fairness in him or her
extracting the value of their
abstract labor their thought their
abstract abilities
their ability to manage the company and
to
engage in proper competition and product
development and efficiency
and the proper treatment of the workers
and all of that and then if they can
create a profit well then they have a
little bit of security for times that
aren't so good and
that seems absolutely bloody necessary
as far as i'm concerned
and then the next thing is well how can
you grow
if you don't have a profit and if you
have an enterprise that's valuable and
worthwhile and
some enterprises are valuable and
worthwhile then it seems to me that a
little bit of profit to help you grow
seems to be the right approach and so
and then the other issue with profit and
you know this if you've ever run a
business is it's really useful
constraint
you know like it's not enough to have a
good idea
it's not a good enough to have a good
idea and a sales and marketing plan
and then to implement that and all of
that that's bloody difficult like it's
not
easy to have a good idea and it's not
easy to come up with a good
sales and marketing plan and it's not
easy to find
customers and satisfy them and so if you
allow
profit to to constitute a limitation
on what it is that you might reasonably
attempt it provides a good constraint on
on wasted labor
and so most of the things that i've done
in my life even psychologically that
were designed to help people's
psychological health
i tried to run on a for-profit basis and
the reason for what
that was apart from the fact that i'm
not averse to making a profit
partly so my enterprises can grow but
was also so that
there were forms of stupidity that i
couldn't engage in because i would be
punished by the market enough to
eradicate the enterprise
and so
[Applause]
okay and then so the next the next issue
this is a weird one
so marx and angles also assume that this
dictatorship of the proletariat which
involves absurd centralization
the overwhelming probability of
corruption
and impossible computation as the
proletariat now try to
rationally compute the manner in which
an entire market economy
could run which cannot be done because
it's far too complicated for anybody to
think through
the next theory is that somehow the
proletariat dictatorship would become
magically hyperproductive
and there's actually no theory at all
about how that's going to happen and so
i had to infer the theory and the theory
seems to be that
once you eradicate the bourgeoisie
because they're evil
and you get rid of their private
property and you
you you you eradicate the profit motive
then all of a sudden magically the small
percentage of the proletariat
who now run the society determine how
they can make
their productive enterprises
productive enough so they become hyper
productive now and they need to become
hyper productive
for the last error to be logically
coherent in relationship to the marxist
theory which is that
at some point the proletariat the
dictatorship of the proletariat will
become so hyper productive
that there'll be enough material goods
for
everyone across all dimensions and when
that happens then what people will do is
spontaneously engage in meaningful
creative labor which is what they had
been alienated
from in the capitalist horror show and
the utopia will be magically ushered in
but there's no
indication about how that
hyperproductivity is going to come about
and there's no also there's also no
understanding that
well that isn't the utopia that is going
to suit everyone
because there are great differences
between people
and some people are going to find what
they want in
love and some are going to find it in
social being and some
are going to find it in conflict and
competition and some are going to find
it in creativity as marx pointed out
but the notion that that that will
necessarily be the end
goal for the utopian state is
preposterous and
then there's the dostoyevsky observation
too which is one not to be taken lightly
which is
what sort of shallow conception of
people do you have that makes you think
that
if you gave people enough bread and cake
and the dostoevsky in terms and
nothing to do with busy them to be
except busy themselves with the
continued
continuity of the species that they
would all of a sudden become
peaceful and heavenly dostoyevsky's idea
was that
you know we were built for trouble and
if we were ever handed everything we
were we needed on a silver platter
the first thing we would do is engage in
some form of creative destruction
just so something unexpected could
happen just so we could have the
adventure of our lives
and i think there's something well
there's something to be said for that
so and then the last error let's say
although
by no means the last was this and this
is one of the strangest parts of the
communist manifest it was
marx it agree admits and angles admit
repeatedly in the communist manifesto
that there has never been a system of
production
in the history of the world that was as
effective at producing
material commodities in excess than
capitalism
like that's that's extensively
documented in the communist manifesto
and so if your proposition is look we
got to get as much
material security for everyone as we
as as possible as fast as we can
and capitalism already seems to be doing
that at a rate that's unparalleled in
human history
wouldn't the logical thing be just to
let the damn system play itself out
i mean unless you're assuming that the
evil capitalists are just going to take
all of the flat screen televisions and
put them in one big room
and not let anyone else have one the
logical assumption is that well you're
already on a road that's supposed to
produce the proper
material productivity and so well that's
ten reasons as far as i can tell that
and so what i saw in that that the
communist manifesto is
is like seriously flawed in in virtually
every way it could possibly be flawed
and also all in in
evidence that marx was the kind of
narcissistic thinker
who could think he was he was very
intelligent person and so was angles
but what he thought what he thought when
he thought was that what he thought was
correct
and he never went the second stage which
is wait a second
how could all of this go terribly wrong
and if you're a thinker especially a
sociological thinker especially a
thinker on the broad scale
a social scientist for example one of
your moral obligations
is to think you know you might be wrong
about one of your fundamental axioms or
two or three or ten
and as a consequence you have the moral
obligation to walk through the damn
system and think
well what if i'm completely wrong here
and things invert and go exactly the
wrong way
like i can't i just can't understand how
anybody could come up with an idea like
the dictatorship of the proletariat
especially after
advocating its implementation for with
violent means which is a direct part of
the communist manifesto
and actually think if they were thinking
if they knew anything about human beings
and the proclivity for malevolence
that's part and parcel of the individual
human being
that that could do anything but lead to
a special form of hell
which is precisely what did happen and
so i'm going to close
because i have three minutes with with
a bit of evidence as well that um
marx also thought that what would happen
inevitably as a consequence of
capitalism
is that rich would get richer and the
poor would get poorer
so there would be inequality the first
thing i'd like to say is we do not know
how to set up a human system
of economics without inequality no one
has ever managed it
including the communists and the form of
in inequality changed and it's not
obvious by any stretch of imagination
that the free market economies of the
west have more
inequality than the less free economies
in the rest of the world
and the one thing you can say about
capitalism is that although it produces
inequality
which it absolutely does it also
produces wealth and all the other
systems
don't they just produce inequality
so here's here's a few stats here's a
few free market stats okay
um from 1800 to 2017
income growth adjusted for inflation
grew by 40 times by for production
workers and 16 times
for unskilled labor um well gdp fact
gdp rose by a factor of about 0.5
from 180 to 1800 so from 180 to 1800 a.d
it was like
nothing flat and then all of a sudden in
the last
217 years there's been this unbelievably
upward movement of wealth
and it doesn't only characterize the
tiny percentage of people at the top
who admittedly do have most of the
wealth
the question is not only though what's
the inequality the question is well
what's happening to the absolutely poor
at the bottom
and the answer to that is they're
getting richer faster now than they ever
have in the history of the world
and we're eradicating poverty in
countries
that have adopted moderate free market
policies at a rate that's unparalleled
so here's an example
the u.n millenni one of the u.n
millennial goals to was to reduce the
the rate of absolute poverty in the
world by 50
between 2000 and 2015 and they defined
that as a dollar 90 a day
pretty low you know but you have to
start somewhere
um we be we we hit that at 2012. three
years ahead of schedule
and you might be cynical about that and
say well it's kind of an arbitrary
number
but the curves are exactly the same at
dollars and 3.80 cents a day and seven
dollars and sixty cents a day not as
many people have hit that but
the rate of increase towards that is the
same the bloody u.n
thinks that we'll be out of poverty
defined by a dollar ninety a day by the
year twenty thirty
it's unparalleled and so so the so the
rich may be getting richer but the poor
are getting richer too and that's
that's not the look i'll leave it at
that
um because i'm out of time but one of
the i'll leave it with this
um
the poor are not getting poor under
capitalism
the poor are getting richer under
capitalism by a large margin
and i'll leave you with one statistic
which is that now
um in in africa the child mortality rate
in africa
now is the same as the child mortality
rate was in europe in 1952
and so that's happened within the span
of one lifetime and so if you're for the
poor
if you're for the poor if you're
actually concerned that the poorest
people in the world
rise above their starvation levels then
the all the evidence suggests that the
best way to do that is to implement
something approximating a free market
economy